okay break it down that like there are
black lives matter protests that are
sometimes organized by like the official
heads of the black lives matter
institution but then other times created
just by like individual actors mm-hmm
and these protests are pretty much
directed at police reform and police
brutality as it's directed towards black
and brown people great then there is a
black lives matter institution which is
like an organized body that accepts like
donations and they have a website with
their mission statement and that's what
I'll pulled up I think the idea is to
dismantle systemic racism and like
improve the lives of blind I think that
those two things potentially could be
separate and I think they it might be
helpful for the discourse if they're
looked at almost as like separate but
like related things because if they're
not looked as separate or related and we
find out that black lives matter the
institution has thoughts about how to
improve the lives of black people
outside of police brutality
then you will have detractors go well I
don't like this thing I'm off board with
black lives matter right as a movement
and you down hundred cent that and also
you might have them go well why don't
you add you know black crime towards
kids to that right list if you got
twenty things make it twenty one where
you know no more black kids get shot
because unfortunately you know a bunch
of them were shot over the weekend I
think in Chicago which I think all black
people like you know we need to stop I
don't think there's any black person out
there's like we don't need to stop black
this is the weird is the concept like of
course it's just like it's like Muslims
with terrorism it's like yeah we want to
stop it
we're the ones dying yeah yeah like
terrorism affects Muslims more than
anybody right so black on black crime
affects black people more then of course
they want to stop it but there's another
institutional problem that also needs to
be stopped I think that mark you
breaking up like that showcases why it's
muddy yeah and I think it's really
important for the movement that that
gets kind of described or figured out I
think you might have been confused
because we first heard of black lives
matter up for the Troy [ __ ] what's name
dude in Florida tell you what more
Trayvon Martin yeah yeah sorry about
that and I think that's I know Ayanna
what
margit i'ma start the episode with it
didn't remember the black live you
[ __ ] sausage away out of that I think
we first heard about the movement during
those protests right and that
highlighted that situation and also
police brutality situations because
Zimmerman wasn't police so that's why
people tied in to just that but the
initial reason they got involved was
just about brutality against black
people it wasn't just about then the
question would be if it's brutality
against black people yeah do they carry
that energy towards brutality against
black people who happen to be black and
like you said I think they wouldn't
disagree with that
we're just saying if we can dismantle
systemic racism that will take care of
itself yeah because it's like right
crime is gonna happen there's white on
white crime right know why he's marching
about that it's like we understand that
crimes gonna happen it's wrong we need
to fix it but things like the police for
example this is an institution that's
paid by our tax dollars like that
shouldn't be right something that we're
fighting against right and an
infringement on your constituent exactly
right no I understand that I think that
is clear to me the and this conversation
comes up every time there is any sort of
criticism of the police you're always
going to have a certain part of people
go well what about black-on-black crime
yeah and if it had nothing to do with
police brutality if it was said in and
of itself I think it would actually be a
really thoughtful thing to bring up
right like if you're saying how can we
improve black communities in America
it's one thing is sorry you can't bring
it up as a retort exactly it's when it's
brought up as a retort hmm it doesn't
seem like you sincerely care it seems
like you're using it as a
counter-argument to black to police
brutality yeah so so I think that
probably in a ma'am you know I'm not
trying to speak for you but I imagine
that's what irks black people so much
about it cuz it's like well you don't
care about you're saying we don't care
about black lines may kill you clearly
don't care either cuz we're
[ __ ] when the police aren't
killing us you know I'm here talking
about what about black on black crime
and you just hear when they're police
person kills yeah so which I get a
hundred percent but I do think it's
something that all that all politicians
should look at and care about anytime
there's a heightened amount of crime
work officers black a black white a
white Asian ladies I don't give a [ __ ]
what is if there's a heightened amount
of crime in an area there should be
efforts made to reduce that yeah and I
don't think anybody would push back just
like you say Aakash it's the retort that
make you resent some [ __ ] you know it's
also an interesting retort to that
retort is you realize black on black
crime does tend to happen more in areas
where there's a lot of police force
so what tells you the police force is
really effective at doing as a job if
we're still killing each other where
there's tons of police well imagine how
much more they be killing is a mark I
think that's completely right like
trying to use a problem as a rebuttal to
a pre-existing problem it shows like a
complete lack of empathy yeah that's how
women argue right it's just like [ __ ]
like you forget to do some [ __ ] right or
like well how am i organizing this
argument to do some [ __ ] they forget to
search it you're like yo you didn't do
that and they're like yeah but you don't
even listen to me anyway you're right
separately say you're sorry and then
tomorrow - I don't listen and I will
listen 100% exactly that's why we don't
like the black on black crime argument
cuz you sound like a bunch of [ __ ]
being ass [ __ ] for real change the
subject guys [ __ ] get out of here
change the subject
check the L on this [ __ ] come on [ __ ]
stupid ass black lives matter
almost
this mother overly real talk now but
that is an interesting point and maybe
it's important to articulate that to be
will use that argument it's like you'll
bring that up with in times of peace or
by all lives matters probably annoying
it's a retort it's a retort we're not
saying your life don't matter to save
this [ __ ] like hold off yeah yo yeah
when all lives matter if you say all
lives matter
guess who agrees yeah I think we'll be
the first ones going finally all arms
matter of this [ __ ] this is lit exactly
[Applause]